ان كوبليفو جنوب اوكرانيا ينضم الينا موفد
فرونس 24 الخاص وسيم الداري وسيم صباح
الخير ما الجديد جديد الوضع الميداني في
اوكرانيا لا سيما في منطقه تاخير سون
نعم نجيب صباح الخير بالرغم من الانسحاب
الروسي انسحاب القوات الروسيه الاسبوع
الماضي من مدينه خرسا وغادات الهجمات
الروسيه بس الصاروخيه همم التوتر لا يزال
قائم في منطقتي خرسه حيث قامت القوات
الروسيه من الضفه الشرقيه لنهر دينيبر
حملات هجوميه بواسطه قذائف الهاون وكذلك
راجمات صواريخ ام 270 وكذلك المدفعيه
الثقيله واستهدفت مناطق في خاضعه تحت
السيطره الاوكرانيه في الضفه الاخرى من
همم نهر النيبرو تمكنت من استهدافه ما وقع
ولا شيء مدينه خرسه همم هذا الهجوم الى
مقتل همم شخص مدني همم اصيب بالشضايا
وكذلك اصفر عن وقوع عدد من الاضرار همم في
المباني وفي الجهه المقابله قامت القوات
الاوكرانيه هي الاخرى بنجوم على القوات
الروسيه المتوقعه في الضفه الشرقيه وتمكنت
من تدمير منظومه حربيه الكترونيه وكذلك
عرب عسكريه كذلك القوات الاوكرانيه ركزته
هجومتها على خطوط الامداد الروسيه
والممرات اللوجستيه في مسعد
الدفع القوات الروسيه الى التراجع في
القواعد والاراضي الخلفيه من الضفه
الشرقيه طبعا في الاثناء همم تجري عمليه
فرض الاستقرار في مدينه خلص ولكن حتى
القوات الروسيه من الاشعه الاخرى تقوم
باخلاء السكان المدنيين الاوكرانيين في
عدد قرى تحت السيطره الاوكرانيه قصرا
وتقوم مصادره ممتلكاتهم وكم كما قامت
مصدره ممتلكات همم والمعدات الطبيه في
مستشفى
وكذلك قامت بالمصادرت سيارات الاسعاف وتم
تحويلها الى شبه جزيره همم
كل ذلك همم تاكدته همم غرفه قياده
العمليات العسكريه الجنوبيه التي اضافت ان
الخطر لا يزال قائم في ظل وجود مش مجموعه
حربيه روسيه همم في البحر الاسود تضم سبعه
سفن حربيه وكذلك غواصه همم علمتنيها اربعه
صواريخ كلمه نعم نعم وسيم متى دعايات هذه
المعارك وهذا القصف على الحياه اليوميه
للاوكرانيه
طبعا ايام عصيبه وقاسيه تنتظر الاوكرانيين
في في خاصه اسبوع المقبل الذي ستنزل فيه
درجات الحراره الى 10 درجات تحت الصفر
طبعا هذه الايام العسيبه همم يعني جراء
الهجمات الروسيه على المنشات الطاقه همم
الهجمات الروسيه الصاروخيه التي وقعت يوم
امس الرئيس الاوكراني اكد ان
عمليه اصلاح هذه الاضرار في المنشات
مستمره ولكن هناك 10 ملايين من
الاوكرانيين محرومون من همم التيار
الكهربائي هذا ما اكده ايضا المدير العام
لشركه الطاقه الذي قال 40% من الاوكرانيين
محرومون من الطاقه خاصه في منطقه السوم
ومنطقه اوديس وقال ان بعض هذه المناطق
سيظل فيها التيار الكهربائي منقطع على عده
ايام في الاسبوع المقبل
كوبيه جنوب اوكرانيا شكرا